[Music]
I'm spending a week in Malaysia my
mission is to master this nation's
unique cuisine I'm on a road trip with
some of the fastest foodies I've ever
met
[Music]
we're leaving the skyscrapers of Kuala
lumper behind and riding an hour out of
the city in search of pure Malay food
[Applause]
[Music]
the bikers are taking me to their
favorite traditional Malaysian Mecca a
roadside restaurant in a sleepy state of
Negri Stan Berlin that was amazing
house nice very cool okay so what kind
of place is this okay this is where
you're gonna eat a real money Malaysian
food ready proper yes
the restaurant is typical on nigras
tamblyn's traditional heritage fewer
immigrants from India and China means
the food is pure Malay so that is one
dish I recognized instantly satay
there's a bit okay and this is chicken
yes delicious that's very good
my god what a difference that's what the
flavor we don't get that nice smoky
charcoal flavor this restaurant has got
another auntie in charge and this one's
got a temper as fiery as a barbecue I'd
love if you don't mind just for 10
minutes to be showing how to make the
rendang
can I join you certainly if you don't
mind me telling you what to do yeah
that's fine I'm used to that yeah aren't
I nice beef rendang is a classic Malay
dish and I want to get my hands on it
and where's the recipe for the recipe is
from my mother really if you ask me I
mean how much onion do you put inside
and I'll say a gaga
what's a Gaga Gaga is like up to you you
know they'll be asking me how much this
how much did yeah I don't know you just
a gaga I know I can see you don't like
giving any away I'll go I'll go
so okay good blenders
I'm not used to getting shoved around
like this I beginning to wish I was
still sitting outside Chili's in yes
it's for everything I'm counting in my
mind so I can I can write the recipe
down in my mind oh don't be shy girl
then just for the demo yeah I'm not sure
I'm [ __ ] myself you might be nervous
so how long we find this off for I got
you a mentally writing this down in my
mind nice and silky you wake me with
this angle and I can tell you how it you
know I mean you don't want to mess with
her would you
I'm just hoping I don't [ __ ] burn
this don't burn my hand down no no I
won't burn it trust me
right now it's more than my life's worth
aren't I knee wants to take a breather
outside I just got a glint in her eye
this is Mike Latorre Abood over here
just over 30 seconds now I know you're
slightly crazy but that is called a
tutorial Bush yes
exactly look like one right does your
husband ever come and pick your clitoral
Bush not here
[Music]
Reisen okay befriend day to finish our
rang down a pot of dry roasted coconut
and its oil thank you
yeah we're coming to the end of the dish
and you started to give me the recipe
new Guardian softer made that's because
you let me touch your bush well I
suppose you did yeah well that's lovely
that's very nice it's not too bad is it
I thought was gonna be bluer excellent
my hungry biker buddies are waiting to
be fed along with our nineties mum
I hope she's less demanding than a
daughter amazing
Annie thank you so much for really
opening my eyes up to proper Malay
cooking yes it's been asked you so much
I'm an agar agar cook and you are a
precise chef so it young really messes
up my mind when you ask how much this
how much today it's all about oh my god
I've understood the difference yeah and
you've really helped open my eyes up to
proper Malay cooking thank you thank you
okay one session in the kitchen would I
need and I can see I've got to do more
than simply learn new recipes
if I'm to master Malaysian cooking
European style cooking is anal it's got
this long list of ingredients that's
weight to the finest detail I got I got
yeah look and learn
watch cook your eyes imagine me walking
in there with a recipe right I need five
ounces of ginger two tablespoons of star
anis no should kick over the ass I boss
him around
I like this now but he loves
men love to be boss